in today's video I'm going to be
reacting to my interview with Piers
Morgan and also give you the truth about
what really happened between the
interview with Piers Morgan and Andrew
Tate but before I kick this video off I
do want to let you know that this video
is sponsored by bitmex so they're an OG
cryptocurrency exchange and an amazing
place to buy and sell many different
cryptocurrencies including Bitcoin if
you do want to get started with crypto
then I'm going to leave all the links
for you in the description below before
we get into it don't forget to hit the
like button and subscribe so you never
miss a video okay so one of the first
things I want to address is whether I
really mean everything that I say yes I
truly meant everything that I said on
the Piers Morgan show and in all my
other interviews there's a lot of
misinformation out there and I think one
of the worst things you can do to
somebody particularly online is misjudge
their character since I know Andrew
personally I felt like I had a
responsibility to do the right thing and
really just say the truth one of the
most controversial topics that piers and
I debated was Andrew saying he prefers
18 year olds to 25 26 year olds now I
don't particularly think this is
misogynistic or there's anything wrong
with it it's just a sexual preference
and I find it so funny that everybody
has an issue with men liking younger
women and they call that sexist
misogynistic but they never have an
issue with women liking older men and
actually that was a point on the show
which I tried to speak about but Piers
Morgan kept interrupting me whenever I
tried to make the point that nobody
calls it sexist when young girls prefer
older men but we'll get into Pierce's
interruptions in a moment having an
issue with the fact that men prefer
younger women is honestly just
ridiculous in my opinion I think it's
ridiculous because if you apply the
logic throughout and across the board
that's like me saying you don't want to
date a trans woman that makes you
transphobic or if you're a white person
and you don't want to date a black
person that makes you racist no it
doesn't it's just a sexual preference so
to conclude this point yesterday
absolutely stand by everything that I
said I felt like there's a lot of
misinformation everybody's
mischaracterizing him and so I really
wanted just to clear the air and here's
the funny part I was ready to have a
one-on-one discussion with just peers
and I turns out that there was so many
more people on the panel and we only
really got to cover two topics the fact
that he prefers younger girls and
whether or not he's a misogynist and to
be honest I was actually slightly caught
off guard because only about five to ten
minutes before we went live I could hear
my earpiece that there are so many more
people in the studio let's talk about
all the different guests that I had no
idea were going to be on the show with
me so there was a guy on the far right I
didn't really know who he was next to me
was Esther who's actually amazing she's
one of my best friends I didn't even
know my best friend was going to be next
to me on Piers Morgan's show which was
pretty cool actually and then there was
a girl on the far left so here's one of
the most ridiculous parts of the
interview this girl on the far left that
hated everything that I had to say
actually made what she thought was a
really rude remark about me but turns
out she was just insulting herself what
he's essentially saying between those
lines is that he wants some sort of
virginal woman maybe that's why he takes
this girl seriously I don't know so
after I'd finished explaining why Andrew
prefers younger girls because they have
a lower body count the girl on the far
left then rolls Horizon says well that's
probably why he prefers her meaning me
she thought that she was insulting me
but actually I'll take that as a
compliment now I want to talk about
something which you guys all know about
it's Piers Morgan's Infamous
interruptions you can say I'm
interrupting you do I swear nobody can
get a word in with that guy especially
when you're about to make an amazing
point every time I was about to make an
amazing point and defend Andrew Tate he
kept interrupting it's the same reason
I don't think that's the misogyny I had
this argument with my sons though when
they saw the clip and because it is his
show I felt out of politeness I should
let him speak and not interrupt him back
but of course you know I really want to
make sure that the truth is out there so
I did try my best to interrupt and to
keep speaking when he was interrupting
me but here's a little sneaky tactic
that they do they actually tend to turn
your mic down so when I want to butt in
and say something I couldn't get
involved and I was getting so frustrated
a lot of people on the panel were saying
the most ridiculous things and I was
just sitting there so frustrated really
wanting to interrupt but like I said my
mic was down so it's just so impossible
and here's the other thing he wasn't
just interrupting me because he
apparently disagreed with me I think he
actually did agree with me in the end
but he interrupted people who held
opposite opinions to me so if you're
just interrupting everyone peers and you
don't let anybody speak why invite us on
the show in the first place and speaking
of interruptions Andrew and I actually
had a conversation about his experience
on Piers Morgan's show because as you
saw it was Interruption by peers every
second and this is the thing that's
interesting Pierce please let me finish
again hang on so Andrew and I actually
had a conversation before I went on
Piers Morgan's show after he had done
the interview Andrew was telling me how
frustrated he was because he thought
that pierce was going to be very
open-minded but he felt it was a little
bit of an ambush and that Piers was
taking what he said out of context
twisting his words and so Andrew
actually told me before I went on the
show to be careful be prepared because
he's gonna really try and trick you and
make you say something that you don't
necessarily mean but that's what Pierce
does Piers wants to always have the last
word he he changed his opinion when he
interviewed Andrew he said that the
misogyny was Andrew preferring younger
women when he interviewed me he said the
misogyny isn't that he preferred younger
women it's the way he said it and then I
tried to tell peers that he was being
extremely emotional about being upset
about not what he said it was the way he
said it but that's if they're all the
same and they've all been through this
emotional Audrey the whole thing was
ridiculous in the end that's why I
wanted to do this video to make sure
that the truth is out there because this
is what mainstream media do they tend to
twist people's words they tend to change
things so that it fits their narrative
and this is why people are ultimately
just falling out with mainstream media
with Legacy Media because they're tired
of their words being twisted and certain
narratives being pushed this is why
people like Andrew Tay are blowing up
people like Jordan Peterson Joe Rogan
because people are absolutely thirsty
for uncensored and unfiltered content
true content which isn't pushing any
narratives which isn't trying to trick
people or twist words people just want
the truth censorship is Rife right now
and that's why I do what I do I can
promise you that when you come to watch
my videos I'm always going to tell you
the truth I'm always going to talk about
things that matter and because there's
just so much misinformation out there
right now and people like Angie Tate are
getting canceled I felt compelled to
speak the truth freedom of speech is so
important if we don't have freedom of
speech we don't have anything I don't
want to be living in a society which
pretends all the time thank you so much
for watching guys and also I want to say
a massive thank you because this channel
has absolutely exploded over the last
few weeks I really appreciate it all the
lovely things that you say I read all
the comments and it's really just so
amazing please don't forget to hit the
like button and subscribe and share this
video because I'm going to be bringing
you even more content this is just the
beginning